le vélo était à l'honneur ce week-end à
verser grand parc la communauté
d'agglomération a organisé ce dimanche 2
juin pour la toute première fois une
fête dédiée à la bicyclette
au programme notamment huit parcours
vélo sur toutes les voies douces du
secteur pour nous c'est un objectif très
important de sensibiliser les gens à
l'utilisation du vélo aussi bien pour
les parcours de de détente que les
parcours aussi en ville pour aller au
bureau et ses allées aux gars donc on a
dit on va développer 90 km de pistes
cyclables et puis on développe aussi des
parkings vélos à l'arrivée pièce d'eau
des suisses à versailles un village avec
des stands a été installé l'occasion
pour les visiteurs de découvrir velits
go un service de location d'un vélo
électrique qui sera lancé le 10
septembre par la région le tarif 40
euros par mois pendant six mois dont la
moitié est prise en charge par
l'employeur
l'idée c'est vraiment d'essayer dans le
quotidien de sa vie pendant une longue
période
au moment où il fait beau des moments où
il pleut et c est ce que le vélo à
assistance électrique mérite
l'investissement qui est quand même
assez important qu'on va faire donc six
mois ça permet de le tester et ensuite
effectivement on le rend ce vélo n'est
pas destiné à être achetés il est
vraiment destiné uniquement à la
location et on le rend pour pour acheter
alors là dans le commerce et les
préinscriptions veliko viennent d'être
lancés la fête du vélo est organisée
partout en france jusqu'à ce dimanche 9
juin